the idea that you need to do
a certain amount of pulling for each set
of pushing you do
and that the ratio of upper body pushing
to pulling strength is super important i
i think part of that may come just kind
of from reasoning from analogy
so
you go back
not not even all that long ago maybe
like 20 years ago or so
there was a lot of research looking at
quad to hamstring strength ratios
and there were some suggestions that if
you had way stronger quads relative to
your hamstrings
that might predispose you for
risk of acl tears and hamstring strains
i haven't checked in on that research in
a long time i don't know if that's still
the current uh consensus view within
within the field uh but but that was
something that a lot of people were
concerned about and there was some
preliminary research suggesting that
that may be the case that if your quads
are way too strong and or your
hamstrings are way too weak you might
strain your hamstrings more frequently
might tear your acls more frequently and
so i wonder if some of the concerns
around shoulder health were just kind of
reasoning from analogy based on that
research where if strength ratios across
the knee seem to matter
to some degree for injury risk maybe
that's a generalizably true phenomenon
that you can generalize to other joints
um
and so
you know
that that may be one of the things
uh motivating the reasoning behind being
concerned about this uh but
as far as i'm aware
there's
like i said to start with as far as i'm
aware there's not good human evidence
validating that those
that you need to have those concerns and
also i'll note that the
sorts of injuries that you might see
at the shoulder tend to be quite a bit
different than than what you'd be
looking at with quadricep to hamstring
strength ratios like the the direct
analogy for a hamstring strain would be
a bicep strain for example um
you know not just kind of
general shoulder algies and the analogy
for an acl strain would be
some sort of uh
strain or tear of the ligaments of the
elbow um like those would be the the
direct analogies you you could draw from
that um
and before a physical therapist gets
angry and corrects us we're talking
about spraining ligaments not straining
them yes correct uh
but yeah so i i mean like the the sorts
of
injuries that you would directly
analogize from the quadriceps to
hamstring strength ratio stuff aren't
even the types of injuries that people
are concerned about uh when you talk
about
shoulder injuries that you might get
from lifting or other sports so i don't
know that the analogy really holds up
and ultimately
reasoning from analogy is a very weak
form of evidence uh ideally you would
have direct human research on the thing
you're interested in
so yeah i mean my my general take on it
is that
for most people who are lifting
certainly doesn't hurt to do more
pulling um
you know a little bit of extra bicep
work you're gripping onto the implement
might grow your forearms a little bit
having a jacked back huge lats huge
traps it's a very cool physique and i'm
not aware of any lifting related pursuit
where that would be a hindrance to you
um
so yeah i mean i i think that if you
are concerned that you need to do a
certain amount of pulling per set of
pushing you do
i i don't think i don't think that's
going to hurt you at all um i think
that's a
you know if even if it does turn out to
be an incorrect idea
the direct applications you would draw
from that idea i don't think are
particularly deleterious so if that does
turn out to be misinformation it's not
harmful misinformation so i don't care
that much um
but as best i can tell
there's not good reliable human data to
suggest that you need to do
a set of pulling per set of pushing in
order to preserve shoulder health